for all of the books I don't have time
for I use short form which condenses
thousands of non-fiction books down into
an excellent summary that I can read or
listen to all at once short form goes
chapter by chapter providing deeper
analysis than other summary platforms
for a more comprehensive understanding
of any topic try it free and get 25 off
using my link below
welcome back from the 4th of July
holiday hope it was good for everybody
no matter what you did it was for some
people a weekend of crimes crimes and
more crimes and in fact the number of
additional possible crimes that we are
learning about related to the 2020
election the time afterwards is wild Ron
DeSantis has also featured me in one of
his campaign ads we're going to talk
about it we were on the ground in
Pickens South Carolina for the Trump
rally Luke Beasley interviewing a bunch
of people the children's critical
thinking book is finally out I've got a
copy here that I'm going to show you it
is an incredible day but to start with I
want to start with an incredible
interview
that one of the failed former president
Donald Trump's press secretaries did
where she says you know this new claim
from Trump that he was talking about
classified documents but he didn't
really have them in his hand it was just
bravado he was just trying to impress
people it it's directly contradicted by
Stephanie Grisham who says I saw him do
it on the Mar-A-Lago patio which for
further suggests that indeed the
recording in which it sounds like Trump
is showing people classified documents
in which he says he's showing people
classified documents we don't need to
look for a complicated explanation the
explanation is he was doing exactly what
he said he was doing showing people
classified documents let's listen here
to an interview on MSNBC with Trump's
former press secretary Stephanie Grisham
look you know Donald Trump is it
plausible Trump was showing classified
documents to people in private meetings
the short answer is yes I watched him
show uh documents to people at
Mar-A-Lago on the on the dining room
patio so he has no respect for
classified information never did
um you know listening to that exchange
every time it just makes me so angry uh
he he talks specifically that he should
have Declassified it but he did it so
there I think is proof I believe also
there's a portion of that audio where he
says you know this is off the Record and
I know Donald Trump knows the rules of
reporters and he knows if it needs to be
off the Record that they can't talk
about it so I think he was covering
himself in that regard and you know I
was thinking about this earlier I just
want to say to your viewers I don't
think people understand how hard it is
to get your um your classified uh
permissions I I remember when I was
going through it to get get all of mine
I got held up because of a 13 KinderCare
a bill that I did not know about and so
I couldn't get experience it went they
go through everything about you it's
very difficult to get a security
clearance and I think people you know
they miss that's in the weeds obviously
but to be showing it to people who
haven't gone through the extreme vetting
that you go through to get it listen uh
we understand where she's going with
this this was not something that only
allegedly happened that one time where
it was on audio recording and it never
otherwise happened and so it's plausible
to say Trump was just talking about
classified documents he wasn't really
showing them to anyone and we've seen
this so many times we see the report
from a Cassidy Hutchinson under oath
during the January 6 committee where she
said Trump lunged at a secret service
agent he snapped and then one of the
defenses we get from Trump and others is
this is completely out of line with how
Trump normally behaves he's never done
this he doesn't snap he doesn't do
anything and then a month ago we got
another report from Trump's plane where
Trump snapped at a reporter on his plane
grabbed his phone and tossed it because
the reporter was asking Trump questions
that he didn't like and didn't want to
answer and then we say oh the one story
has now become more than one story and
yet they love to insist that every
single one of these stories is
completely out of character for Trump at
this point it is extraordinarily
difficult to take seriously even for a
second that Trump was talking about
classified documents
saying this is off the Record
audibly shuffling papers but that they
were actually Golf Course plans as he
has asserted at least at one time since
this audio report came out crimes crimes
and more crimes and now we go from the
east coast to the southwest of the
United States and let's talk about more
possible crimes in Arizona
I need 11 000 votes give me a break
that's a quote that many of us remember
that relates to Georgia that was during
a phone call that the failed twice
indicted twice impeached former
president had on the phone with Georgia
officials saying I only need 11 000
votes to defeat Joe Biden give me a
break let's find those votes Trump
claims he was saying just I think I won
let's just find the legal votes every
other sane person in the world who heard
the audio tape says no Trump's trying to
coerce and say find a way for me to win
even if Joe Biden actually won it turns
out that it was not only in Georgia that
Trump was doing this and this once again
fits this theme we get one report and
many of his Defenders say so out of
character he would never do this we now
have two independent unrelated reports
Washington Post exclusive report from
our friend Leanne Caldwell from the uh
Community Radio Days Josh dossey and
Yvonne winget Sanchez Trump pressured
Arizona governor Doug Ducey to overturn
the 2020 election it's it reads just
like the Georgia story but it's a
different story in a phone call in late
2020 Trump tried to pressure Republican
Arizona governor Doug Ducey to overturn
the state's presidential election
results saying that if enough fraudulent
votes could be found it would overcome
Trump's narrow loss in Arizona according
to three people familiar with the call
Trump also repeatedly asked vice
president Mike Pence to call Ducey and
prod him to find the evidence to
substantiate Trump's claims of fraud
Pence called Ducey several times to
discuss the election
they said though he did not follow
Trump's directions to pressure the
governor the extent of Trump's efforts
to cajole Ducey into helping him stay in
power has not before been reported even
as Trump's other efforts have been made
public Ducey told reporters in December
2020 that he and Trump had spoken but
declined to disclose the contents of the
call although he disagreed with Trump
about the outcome of the election Ducey
has sought to avoid a public battle from
Trump notably Ducey did not record the
call according to people familiar with
the matter so we now have yet another
story we have now heard if you look
nationally from County election
officials
state election officials state
legislators we have heard from all of
these different levels about a very
specific sort of plan
we know that there were elements to this
attempted coup that went all the way to
the White House it included the January
6 rioters the halls of Congress fake
electors in various States pressure
phone calls attempts to commandeer
voting machines remember every one of
these little details would have been a
crisis if Obama had done it that's for
sure
but they are just yet another instance
when it comes to Trump there was that
period right after the elections where
Trump said sequester the voting machines
get voting machines
officials went to Trump and said what
are you talking about we can't really do
that what do you mean just bring them
here to the White House it doesn't make
any sense we at this point can make a
couple of conclusions number one these
people were not randomly acting alone
you didn't randomly have
fake electors in Arizona and fake
electors in Wisconsin all trying to do
the same thing just by Miracle incidents
it is obvious that this was a concerted
and coordinated effort number two
some of the same tactics and techniques
were attempted in multiple States the
pressure phone calls were attempted in
Georgia and the pressure phone calls
were attempted in Arizona now the
questions that remain and I don't
pretend to have the answers at this time
we just don't know is special prosecutor
Jack Smith looking into what we just
learned about from Arizona is it
possible that this will become part of
his investigation or is this being
independently investigated at the state
level in Arizona much like fonnie Willis
is investigating the same in Georgia
from which we will soon know the outcome
sometime between next week and early
September we don't know the answer to
that but what is abundantly clear is
that this was a concerted effort loony
Lindsey Graham seemed to have been
involved in multiple places by the way
Lindsay brutally booed at a trump rally
over the weekend we'll talk about that
in a moment that's the latest and it is
crimes crimes and more crimes Rhonda
sanctimonius is now using me David
pakman in one of his newest campaign ads
this was published over the Fourth of
July holiday this is an ad that uh not
only includes me but it includes our
friend Faron cousins from Ring of Fire
and many others the point that the ad
tries to make is that we on the left
we're all scared of Ron DeSantis what
we're actually saying in the clips that
are used
is that we think DeSantis is more
dangerous than Trump to some degree
because he's less incompetent and that's
true it's actually not a terrible ad the
context is we all think DeSantis is nuts
take a listen to this and you will see
me pop up a number of times if Trump was
the original Terminator the Sanctus is
like the T-1000 Miranda Santos is far
more dangerous than Donald Trump a more
disciplined extremist they're just like
oh well at least DeSantis isn't crazy
like Trump but I'm like no you should be
more scared of him than Trump he's more
Savvy he's more Coy and he doesn't have
the pitfalls that Donald Trump does the
real reason this man is so terrifying
is because he's managed to succeed in
areas where Trump has failed if anyone
out there thinks that somehow he is any
better than Donald Trump then they don't
know Ron DeSantis if you thought Donald
Trump was fat you got another thing
Tommy he may actually be able to do a
lot of the things Trump merely wanted to
do but failed to do the census actually
knows the system and I think Rhonda
Sanchez is far more dangerous than
Donald Trump but he's also more
competent I think earlier than Trump
because he's not so incompetent he's
more cunning he's not an incompetent
administrator the way that Trump was he
would be more uh able to get things done
Ron DeSantis is far more dangerous than
Donald Trump far more dangerous than
Donald Trump far more likely if he
becomes president to successfully
Implement a lot of these horrible and
disastrous ideas now you'll notice that
when I mention horrible and disastrous
ideas they put the word awesome on the
screen with a little asterisk so you
know I I saw a comment about this ad
um that it's very creepy that they're
proud of this to a reason reasonable
person like if you just put aside party
affiliation
DeSantis seems like he's running for
dictator I read a number of comments
like this in response to my tweet about
this video but these are such weird
times that because the highest virtue is
triggering the left and triggering the
libs they actually get mileage
from so many people saying this guy is
dangerous for his authoritarian ideas I
saw another comment that said this ad
would be more effective if they left out
the parts where we're all calling
DeSantis dangerous like they they could
have gotten rid of all of those things
and the ad would actually be stronger
but it's almost like a badge of honor
that much of the country including folks
like me
see DeSantis is incredibly dangerous saw
another response to this ad which was
along the lines of trying to Pander to
the right by bragging about how much of
a fascist you want to be is a pretty bad
strategy if you make it to the general
election and there's actually a lot of
insight there as I've said before the
way DeSantis is running this campaign
is maybe useful in a Republican primary
and maybe not because he's making no
progress whatsoever against Trump still
pulling low 20s but the anti-woke stuff
the I'm a wannabe dictator stuff the
left thinks I'm dangerous stuff
it might play well in a Republican
primary and it might not but I don't see
any way that this is useful to DeSantis
in a general election now a couple
people wrote to me and said David you
should sue him for using you in the
video I have not consulted with an
intellectual property attorney on this
it seems pretty clear to me that if you
are a candidate for office and there are
people publicly commenting about your
candidacy for office that all of that
stuff is fair use that that's my
instinct I have no interest in suing I'm
more interested in the fact that he's
now using me in a campaign ad let me
know your thoughts make sure you were
subscribed to the YouTube channel as we
press forward uh towards two million
YouTube subscribers I believe we should
save the recording of today's show
because it's actually a pretty good show
I hope you'll stay with me
I often have a much longer list of
non-fiction books that I'd like to read
than I actually have the time for and
that's when summaries of books can be
really useful our sponsor short form is
the platform that goes Way Beyond what
other book summary platforms do because
short form provides a clear and concise
overview of the book that you can read
or listen to in one sitting but you also
get a ton of other crucial context about
how the book fits into the broader topic
like for example I went through the
short form guide for an American
sickness it's a book by Elizabeth
Rosenthal about the financial incentives
that plague the U.S health care System
many of which we've talked about short
form perfectly sums up the book's key
points but then it goes further it looks
at the background on how rosenthal's
perspective fits into the larger debate
on American Health Care and this just
gives you a more complete and balanced
understanding of the book and that's
what I love about short form short form
has every non-fiction genre imaginable
and they publish new book guides every
single week my audience can try short
form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription if you'd like at
shortform.com Pacman the link is down
below
we were on the ground in Pickens South
Carolina for Donald Trump's Fourth of
July weekend rally our correspondent
Luke Beasley was there now if you've
been following the show for a while you
know that Luke's done some wild
interviews
I believe they all pale in comparison to
what Luke saw there this weekend and
Luke's done a great job but the level of
nuttiness and cultishness that we saw
there this weekend is something to
behold this is likely the best and worst
one ever now remember you can find
Luke's YouTube channel at
davidpackman.com Luke Luke and I
strategize before this event and I said
it might be useful it might be
interesting
to focus in specifically on the
indictment and the audio tape of trump
admitting to crimes
I was shocked myself at how insane the
answers from these folks were let's
start with this first guy completely
confused
understands nothing cannot think quite
frankly shocking he can even get dressed
in the morning listen to this what are
your thoughts on the Federal indictment
my thoughts oh I'm not worried about it
not worried like you don't think he did
what he's being accused of
it's like you know they hand out
diamonds like cookies yeah oh he's only
been died twice
I mean
like so you have the Manhattan D.A and
then the federal oh that Manhattan D.A
what a piece I mean a porn star I mean
it looked
every rich person had sex with a porn
star yep already Family Values though
right huh already a family values right
I mean I've had sex with a porn star
oh God here we go
really really you know I
I'm not gonna comment on that
okay you judge for yourselves
whether this young man
had sex with a porn star all right
and you would be a good candidate in the
party of family values you know what we
all make mistakes it's so show me a man
with no convention conviction of the
past you know show me a man who I mean I
I have no convictions in my past just
never said a cuss word show me a man
that's never you know had perverted
thoughts show me a man preferred her
thoughts about their own daughter like
Trump
I think I was a joke he said that on The
View they'll defend anything anything
he'll defend and uh that was on The View
and he said he would like to he said if
he was dating somebody he would date a
woman like his dog the most reading uh
recent reporting says that they're
defending Trump fantasizing about his
own daughter
folks the white house he has been
overheard fantasizing about having sex
with her how does that relate what's
going on right now I just think it's
gross
but but she asked me what do I think
about his indictment why I know he's
brought a porn star so here we are look
I mean look we've all looked at porn
there you go oh you know we're just
really going
so what this is the first clip I saw
from what Luke sent me
and I said oh my goodness if this is
what this is going to be like this is
going to be crazy it actually gets even
more nuts here is a guy Luke explains
what about ISM to this guy
and the guy doesn't get it and just
responds with more what about ISM I mean
there's an inability to be able to think
here arguments oh what about ism
no what is it uh it's a logical fallacy
when you try to respond to someone's
argument kind of break down someone's
argument by just referencing something
else separate from the conversation you
guys do that all the time I have no you
can't talk to also what about is it
right there I know the point is you
can't talk to a liberal you're talking
to one right now
I could wrap you around my finger in two
seconds the bottom line is careful I
don't know what that means okay what it
means is you've been lying so long you
don't know how to tell the truth
what it also means is you've stayed
really quite aligned that applies to
Trump right you've been lying so long
you don't know how to tell the truth
reach the entire Insanity for so long
you still don't know how to tell the
truth so we're unraveling it it's like a
piece of thread on the sweater so do you
agree hard and you guys are losers do
you agree the Espionage Act outlines
certain things you can and can't do with
classified material yeah so why do you
agree on an audio don't you agree same
thing for bug because we don't have
evidence that he did the same things
Trump did not only did he do it he had
no authority to do it as vice president
he obstructed investigation didn't
classify anything he wanted as president
but this piece of direct can't do
anything as vice president do you
understand let's bring the heat down and
just let me ask an honest question in
the recording that's been released now
you can hear Trump saying this is still
classified I could have Declassified as
president but I didn't know okay he
didn't know I didn't no no he didn't
know he did know it doesn't matter here
he didn't know or it doesn't matter but
why is isn't Biden in prison by now he
talked to the FBI months earlier I said
give us the documents give us a document
help you not a problem you guys are
creating a mountain out of a mobile
because you don't want him to run that's
how stupid you are you're afraid that
all this is going to materialize on a
much bigger scale and he gets elected
that's why you guys can't handle it
this guy is really a piece of work and
when Luke confronts the exact same guy
with facts about what Trump did the
substance of the indictment the guy says
grow up
and mentions China I'm not kidding this
is these folks vote so we've got to make
sure we're voting and the people that
are in charge are so evil and so
disgusting and so fascist all of us are
vulnerable including you
if they don't like you just look at what
they're doing to Trump just realize that
but like I would never hold on to
classified documents and then lie to
Federal authorities and then dropping
investigation and then conspire with
staffers to hide the contents
right throw up please okay that's our
priority look what's going on around the
world
China Russia so what about worried about
documents yeah more what about ISM there
as you can see the next guy confidently
says the indictment is garbage but he
hasn't read it and says the audio
recording is garbage but he didn't
listen to it and then when he gets
pinned up against the wall with facts he
says doesn't everybody do the same thing
that Trump did uh what are your thoughts
about the Trump indictment uh
it's probably garbage probably garbage
did you read it no okay and then what
about the audio recording that got
released probably garbage you didn't
listen to it
how would you know it's garbage if you
don't even look into it
some serious things are being uh accused
here
like tell me what it is mishandling and
uh classified documents holding on to
them when he wasn't supposed to have
them all right uh violating a subpoena
lying to Federal authorities obstructing
investigations and conspiring with other
staffers to move around documents to
keep federal authorities from getting
them it's like stealing a candy bar guys
come on
sounds uh sounds pretty serious but
doesn't everybody do that
this would be a comedy if it wasn't so
serious and so tragic and so sad doesn't
everybody do all that exact same stuff
all right then we go and we hear from a
woman
who is suspicious of the audio recording
of trump admitting to crimes she's
suspicious that it even really exists
she's like there is no audio tape that's
weird and then another woman pops up and
they both seem really confused and
you'll notice they don't know anything
they use words whose meaning they don't
understand they are their mouths are
moving I hear noise I recognize the
words they don't know the meaning of
these words listen to this well it's
like why do they have an auto recording
I mean that's like going back to
Superman with uh you know the olseness
the reporter carrying a little recorder
why didn't they have video they could
have had him on video but they didn't
you know it's just it's plus he has the
presidential he has with no discretion
he has no discretion she doesn't even
know what she's saying ever he can take
his
you know that the record side of the
presidential
protect but
but is being charged with the Espionage
Act Right or violating it no he he in
detects everything
they had the opportunity to go through
everything right and they told him just
to put some better locks on then they
came back you know
um there you go he has the right as a
president to certify and do or
declassify this is Obama's uh fourth run
there you go
but Obama's running for the fourth time
right now Obama
Obama's fourth presidency he's
controlling stuff yeah absolutely the
only thing Obama hasn't checked off of
his list yet is um freedom of speech he
wants that gone and he's campaigning
everywhere on every platform and he can
get on and that's one of the main things
weaponize the FBI weaponized so what's
interesting is
some of the vocabulary of the conspiracy
theories has trickled down into their
brains they just don't really understand
it or know how to use it airas and
freedom of speech and guns all of that
he wants those are on his little
checklist and that's what he's doing yep
it's actually it's quite fitting that
this interview is being done in front of
a row of about a dozen porta potties
because everything coming out of the the
mouths of these people really deserves
to be flushed 10 to 15 times
um then uh speaks to two more women who
say the tape doesn't exist and
um it must be AI it must be actually
it's not really Trump if there is a tape
it's AI
um okay and then one of the big things
in the news right now is that tape of
trump caught on recording no that that
has been debunked that there it doesn't
exist have you not heard that
that tape does not exist I heard it it
doesn't fake like AI Trump voice it must
be because they tried to produce it and
they couldn't produce it because it does
not exist even though I listened to it
it might have been AI I don't know but
if they tried to produce the actual tape
there is a I think there's there's film
but there's no sound there you go in
fact there is there is no video that I'm
aware of
uh when Trump got asked about it he just
said no no in the recording I
he didn't deny that he said all the
things in the recording why wouldn't he
say oh that was fake if it was fake no
I'm not in his head
that's a good question even Trump's not
denying the authenticity of the
recording he's just saying he wasn't
really showing anybody papers I don't
know I don't know what Trump's thinking
um fascinating stuff then we go to a guy
this guy is probably racist as my sense
this guy refers to Luca's boy he said
hey boy
let's listen what that man is talking is
the only person
alive on this Earth that can save this
Republic peacefully
peacefully right
right now if he's not elected
you listen to this boy
folks this is not not an actor
Central Casting right as Trump like says
this is not an actor as far as we know
Republic shall survive
regardless of what the hell it takes
okay poke that over in your pipe
I'm smoking it okay the guy says to Luke
smoke that in your pipe he says in
calling Luke boy
he says uh Trump's the only guy who can
peacefully save us but if he loses then
all bets are off and it's very much not
going to be peaceful and the last guy
Luke spoke to this stuff needs to be in
the National Archives really
um Luke speaks to a guy with no shirt on
who it hasn't read the indictment hasn't
heard the audio but he has really strong
feelings about both do you think
lokeness I hear a lot about wokeness on
the right is that a big problem
uh uh like being woke like these woke
companies yeah yeah for sure how would
you define a woke woke like leave the
damn kids alone that's for sure that
pisses me off right Wilkes leave the
dick kiss it
dude I didn't want to get into this too
deep and stuff like that because I do
got to carry on but basically just being
woke like you're just shoving crap down
our throats like you have to do this and
you have to do that and you have to obey
this and you can't say that because
Sally over there is going to get
offended and you can't read this book
you can't be gay Etc yeah dude all sorts
of things and it's annoying I'm sick of
it I just want people to be happy there
you go and then then they actually get
to the part about the indictment here
here's that so with the indictment have
you read it and have you heard the audio
recording that's been a big thing in the
news not too much in depth about it so
it's a little strange to me
since it's like such a big thing against
him and he's saying that Biden's
weaponizing the government against them
you know so then wouldn't it be good to
know if that's happening or not no yeah
I mean like it totally it totally is
it's just like with Trump having to go
to court on multiple different occasions
for like all this stuff that the uh the
buttons are doing you know what I mean
with Hunter and Joe and all these trades
and this secret crap that's going on you
know and and then it's just like it's
kind of like hey look over here look at
look at Donald Trump you know like we're
arresting him and we're doing this and
that while they're doing all that
crooked stuff someone are do you agree
that right now they don't have hard
evidence otherwise they would be
broadcasting it on Fox News James Comer
admits we don't have the evidence right
now but we think we have the evidence
yeah I mean it's totally there so then
wouldn't it be like oh wait you think
that was there yeah I mean I think that
the stuff is there it's one of those
things that like I feel like they gotta
like put it out uh in a certain way like
a strategic they've got all the evidence
against Biden they're just waiting three
years to put it out kind of way you
can't just like blast it out there
because maybe stuff gets uh like spoiled
or some sort you know it's just let me
put it this way it's like if you leave
if you if you leave Mayo out too long it
spoils same thing with the evidence
against Biden you agree that I right now
can't see the evidence that's being
referred to I can't listen to the
recordings that are being like yeah no I
understand in that sense some people
would think maybe Trump we can read the
evidence in the indictment what they're
uh alleging and then hear the audio
which is one of the pieces of evidence
ourselves we can listen to it
we can't do the same with the buying
stuff so maybe the buying stuff is
actually Republican trying to distract
from the Trump stuff no yeah honestly
dude I feel like at this point we just
don't know until it actually happened so
with the indictment until what right
there may not be an indictment that
happened that's the whole point because
it doesn't appear as though they have
any evidence against Joe Biden
um incredible work by Luke this is what
we're up against and we have to support
Independent Media so remember you can go
over to Luke's Channel davidpackman.com
Luke and subscribe please make sure that
you're subscribed here last month in in
June a record three and a half million
people watched our videos but didn't
subscribe it's free to subscribe on
YouTube support the work we and others
are doing it is so important make sure
that you do that all right this has been
a long time coming and I'm super excited
and nervous about this because I don't
know how it's going to go I've teased
for a while that we've been working on a
children's book on critical thinking as
so many of you know I've identified one
of the many problems we have in
education in the United States is we're
not teaching critical thinking to kids
nearly early enough
I've written with our team a book for
kids on critical thinking I have the
first proof
right in front of me and I'm holding it
up this one labeled not for resale
this book
is now available on Amazon
we did an email blast this morning
and the copies are flying off the
shelves it is unbelievable what's going
on
I don't pretend for a second that this
40 page book including illustrations and
dedication and everything that this 40
page book is going to solve the critical
thinking crisis we have but this is a
book that six seven eight-year-olds can
read with their parents uh 9 10 11 12
year olds can read by themselves it is
about starting to think critically when
someone says something how do we know
that it's true how do we know that we
know anything
I can't tell you I I've heard from
people saying David I'm buying 25 copies
I'm going to bring them to my local
libraries and give them uh give them
away I'm buying these as gifts for I
don't have kids but I'm buying them for
my my nephews and so on and so forth
it's available in Kindle and in
paperback the Kindle is pre-order it's
going to launch Tuesday pre-order it now
please help us with the pre-orders only
a couple hundred pre-orders
can put us at number one for the
category this is you know we're used to
hundreds of thousands and millions being
the numbers we talk about on YouTube and
podcast Etc a few hundred orders of this
book today will put us at the top of the
category and then all bets are off
uh I want to
um also mention that this copy I have
here is the first proof we're going to
call it like proof zero I am going to
give this proof away to someone who buys
the book I'll tell you how to take
advantage of that in the future
everybody who buys it will be eligible
so I'll be doing that I'll I'll give
this copy away I got two proofs one I'm
Gonna Save for my daughter who by the
way loves the book already she can't
read she just loved the pictures
probably is going to rip the book up
very very soon so I may need to get a
couple more proofs uh you go to
davidpackman.com book
that's it davidpackman.com book uh make
sure to leave a review
Kindle paperback I'm going to update you
on how this goes but it is a super
exciting new thing that we're doing and
it is only available
at davidpackman.com book we'll take a
quick break and be back right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with Dr
Ami Clin who's director of the Marcus
Autism Center at Emory University School
of Medicine and Children's Healthcare of
Atlanta Dr Clint thanks for joining me I
really appreciate your time today
it's my pleasure so we're going to talk
about autism I think maybe a good
starting point is what is our
understanding today in 2023 of what
autism is because over the decades there
have been discussions both
well-intentioned and sometimes not about
whether autism is a quote mental illness
or is it a neurological disease or or
what is it what is our understanding
today of what autism is
autism is a developmental condition
which means that it is
um visible from a child from the time
that a child is is born and he has
genetic Origins primarily which
basically means that um uh
Iran's in families and
um if I have a child devotism for
example
um one or two in every five younger
siblings would also have autism so it's
a it's a highly heritable it's a
strongly genetic condition I say
developmental because impacts the
development of the social brain autism
is a condition that impacts the child's
ability to
um to develop relationships to acquire
speech language communication to be able
to navigate the demands of everyday
social life successfully and it's
something that is considered to be a
genetic trait and whether or not it
becomes a disability it happens over
time
and it's a very broad spectrum from
children who are very significantly
affected to individuals who are much
less so from individuals who have
intellectual disabilities to individuals
who are much brighter than you or I so
um it's the most common complex
neurodevelopmental condition
so when we think about
um genetically based and to some degree
heritable it's not like you said it's
not a guaranteed heritability but there
is this idea that it runs in families
there's this question of the when autism
develops are we to understand that based
on what you're saying this is something
that is sort of set and fixed in the
womb
it is not it is not and that's a really
important message to your listeners
um autism is strongly genetic but it's
very complex with many hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of uh of genes
already implicated in autism each one of
them comparing a very low amount of risk
and so it's a little bit like traits
that a child is born with which means
that they have an attenuated sense of
others and uh and this um and as a
result of that
um they accrue uh hundreds and hundreds
thousands of thousands of missed
opportunities of social learning and so
um the autistic symptoms they emerge in
the second year of Life as a result of
the Divergence in their development from
that of their peers uh and what and what
that means is that where we to be able
to identify the children very early on
and provide them with early treatment
and services and supports
um their outcomes uh could be optimized
so it's absolutely not inevitable and
most importantly it's now within our
reach to be able to optimize their
outcomes and our ultimate goal really is
to change The Narrative of autism from
one of disability to one of promise and
diversity when when we talk about
intervention and treatment
what are we talking about in other words
what what are what do we say what do we
mean when we say treatment of autism
um uh treatment for autism would mean
different things at different stages of
a person's life and depending on the
level of disability of an individual
child adolescent or adult but in regards
to early treatments and services meaning
for children who are infants and
toddlers it goes back to the fact that
what moves a brain development forward
early on is the mutually reinforcing
choreography between infant and
caregiver
is that dance this back and forth that
uh is at the basis of a child's ability
to speak to acquire language and to
communicate with others and so all of
the uh treatments that are available to
us uh early in people's lives have to do
with strengthening that connection
between infants and caregivers and
ensuring that uh this back and forth
moves forward so that they can acquire
all of the skills that they need to uh
to communicate with others and develop
relationships therefore a lot of those
treatments are caregiver mediated
meaning we train parents to engineer
that connection so that they can do that
in the home or in every different or in
every possible setting so that
um they can have a role in advancing
their own child's growth let's talk
about prevalence
um prevalence is cited in many different
contexts including some we'll talk about
a little bit later when it comes to
phenomena in society we'll get back to
that but when we talk about prevalence
how does prevalence today compare to our
understanding of the prevalence of
autism at times past do we have a better
understanding so now we have changed the
threshold for diagnosis or are there
genuinely more autistic people being
born today than in times past help us
understand that a little bit
sure
um uh and you're absolutely right right
prevalence has been rising for for many
years when I was in training we used to
say uh that there was one person in
autism for every 2 and 500 individuals
and nowadays according to this the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention that is one in 36
that's an enormous increase
we say for example now that in this
country uh 95 000 children will be born
in the US every year who will have
autism and if we went by the prevalence
of say 40 years past uh it would be only
about the Thousand four hundred and
that's not even the number in one of the
50 states so absolutely prevalence has
been rising
um and what the science has shown is uh
several things number one uh we're
finally getting things is Right meaning
that the number of individuals with
autism that we find in the community
depends on how we go about trying to
find them yeah and so there was a time
in which we waited in our clinics to
count the individuals who walked through
our doors the CDC has changed uh those
uh those kinds of methodologies and what
we have seen is a much more
comprehensive survey of the population
and those studies happen uh every two
years and what we have seen is that the
prevalence has been rising every two
years and every time we get a little bit
better in reaching a particular
Community because in the past minorities
low-income families and rural families
were not truly represented in the
population that we survey in order to
get a sense of how many individuals of
autism are out there so that's one of
the factors so one factor is we are
better at serving the whole population
the the second part is
do you as a top person in this field
believe that there is actually a higher
prevalence among the population separate
from our ability to measure it
um
a very important factor is the one that
you alluded before our understanding of
autism has changed dramatically in the
past 30 years or so so
um the definition of autism or what we
recognize autism is much broader than
what we used to think the onion of
course the moment that you brother the
the definition you will going to find
um uh more people there is no uh there
is no question about that
um but I have to tell you
um there is a difference in terms
between prevalence and incidents and
um you mentioned do you believe that
there are more children being born with
Autism now than before uh the answer is
very likely no because incidence means
the truth about a condition in the
community right
um what we have seen is that that might
not be the case and what is the case is
the children or the individuals that we
are able to ascertain and find and
document their autism
um and I'll just give you a brief
example for it
um a few years ago
um there was a dramatic increase in the
prevalence of autism and in one
community in particular the Latino
Community the prevalence has arisen by
over a hundred and ten percent so it did
not mean that all of a sudden there are
more children from Latino communities
being born with audited what it really
meant is that we're finally knocking on
their doors and now counting them too
when it comes to some of the
controversies as to autism's cause no
doubt you're aware that there is a
conversation that has been going on for
15 years about vaccines
BPA lining in food cans has been
discussed Wi-Fi signals are diets lack
of exercise the wrong exercise video
games you know I mean I don't have to
give you the full list some of these are
more commonly discussed than others very
generally do we have any sense about
causal or lifestyle factors right now as
they relate to autism
I understand why when a condition is
poorly understood there are plenty of
theories but if your listeners include
parents and I hope uh they are listening
to us
um uh this this various different
theories have proven have been proven
over and over and over to be wrong
so for example vaccines don't cause
autism vaccines save lives other
environmental factors that have been
studied have not been shown to be causal
of autism so it's very important for
people to understand that autism is not
a disease autism is not like cancer
you asked me beforehand if if autism was
inevitable and I was telling you no it's
not inevitable what does that means it
means that it is a trait
children are born with an attenuated
sense of other people and because they
fail to engage others in this back and
forth we call social interaction they
end up developing the symptoms called
autism
um and and there are many ways in which
this dance between infants and
caregivers can be disrupted the most
important one in autism is this genetic
trait we talked about this autism being
highly heritable and strongly genetic
that is the uh the most well
substantiated cause of autism but you
can also develop autism if you disrupt
infant caregiver interaction through
things such as for example prematurity
or if a child goes through say
repeated uh surgical interventions if
the child is born if congenital heart
disease uh eight to twelve percent of
very low gestational age uh children
develop autism as do children with
congenital heart disease uh it's
basically if you disrupt that either
because you have a neurological insult
or because you have a genetic trait like
what autism is you can end up showing
the symptoms of autism but there is no
substantiation of any environmental
Factor whatsoever to date having said
that among low-income families the fact
that there are what we call social
determinants of Health that basically
puts families at disadvantage because
there is trauma or because of poverty or
because there is a very let's say
impoverished linguistic environment in
the home well those factors can
aggravate autism but they don't cause
autism I know we only have a few minutes
left but there were a couple of other
things I wanted to ask about as you said
if the term cure may not be an
appropriate term because as you say
autism is not a disease in the way that
cancer is a disease given what we know
about the likely genetic basis do you
think that as we move forward with Gene
therapies that Gene therapies may come
in to play a role when it comes to
autism in some way
um unlike other genetic disorders uh
that are caused by a single gene or a
small number of genes autism uh the
genetic basis of autism includes
hundreds and probably by the time we
finish
discovering all of the genes that are
implicating autism that will be over a
thousand it's very very unlikely that a
genetic therapy is going to make let's
say a contribution to
um to individuals of autism's quality of
life it is much more likely and much
more pressing and much more imminent
that we as a society are going to
identify children earlier and provide
treatments that are already available to
us as the ones that we discussed before
and the notion here just as you said
it's not to cure autism is not to
eradicate that trait is to ensure that
children with that trait have the very
best possible outcome they can have and
the fact is that the majority of
individuals with autism uh do not have
intellectual disability and they are
making extraordinary contributions to
society every day what we want is that
all children have an opportunity to make
that contribution and to live fulfilling
lives
we've been speaking with Dr Ami Clin
who's director of the Marcus Autism
Center at Emory University School of
Medicine I really appreciate your time
and insights today thank you
it's my pleasure thank you
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show earlier we
looked at clips of interviews that Luke
Beasley did with Trump supporters at his
rally in Pickens South Carolina over the
holiday weekend let's now look at clips
of the actual rally one of the most
interesting things was that Republican
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham
was brutally brutally booed he had a
speech himself and he was booed and ran
off stage and then when Trump talked
about him he was also booed here is
Lindsay cutting it short
after getting heckled the entire time
and running off of the stage you you
really you love to see it you really do
God Bless America
[Music]
a visibly frustrated Lindsey Graham
brutally booed by a supposedly friendly
Maga crowd and walks off stage when
Trump mentioned Lindsay the crowd also
not convinced twice not you know you can
make mistakes on occasion
even Lindsay down here Senator Lindsey
Graham would love something wicked we're
gonna love him
we're gonna love him
I know it's half and half but what I
need some of those liberal votes he's
always there to help me get him okay
right
we got some pretty liberal people but
he's good he's good we know the good
ones we know the bad ones crowd is very
very very very much not convinced Trump
then going into woke going into elements
of woke and says nobody knows what
wokeness is
for women and you know the amazing thing
because of our crazy woke society and I
hate the word woke actually because
nobody even has a real accurate
description it means lack of Common
Sense more than anything else but
because
sorry sir woke means you are aware of
injustices in society and you'd like to
fix them at least if it's possible Trump
as news was breaking about his phone
call to pressure Arizona's Governor to
overturn the 2020 election results
weighed in during his speech about his
phone call to try to get Georgia
officials to overturn the election
results and he continues to exist
insists rather this was just a perfect
call copy of it it was a perfect call
these were perfect calls these were
calls where you're questioning the
validity
and the safety of Elections and it's a
disgrace that they're allowed to even
think about it but not one person
protested until long after that call
right and if there was something wrong
with that call I am not a stupid person
number one I'm an honest person so I
wouldn't do it anyway but when people
are on the opponent Trump would know
whether there was anything right or
wrong whether there was anything wrong
with the call that's not true Trump
doesn't know anything and Trump would
never lie about the call that's not true
Trump lies all the time many lawyers do
you think many people were on that phone
many many people do you think I'm going
to say what they'd like to have but the
problem is
it's not borne out I will tell you what
is born out the call was supposedly
taped in the State of Florida and on
Florida you're not allowed to do you
know that's a two-party state in other
words you're not allowed to take phone
calls they taped the phone call to show
you how nice they are they take the
phone calls all right so Trump rambling
and rambling about that none of us
believe it and then lastly Donald Trump
directly attacking special prosecutor
Jack Smith it's hard to believe this is
a good strategy for the presidential
records act well that's what they should
be looking at because everything I did
was under the presidential records act
we have a thug prosecutor
named Smith Jack Smith he's a thug he's
had many losses he's destroyed many
lives and they put him in charge in the
meantime what about Biden's records this
guy has 1850 boxes he has boxes stored
in Chinatown in DC rough place by the
way and Trump continuing to tell the
same debunked lies about Joe Biden and
his documents it's the greatest hits but
I have to tell you even the cult crowd
seems a little bit skeptical but not the
cultists were about to look at video of
it wasn't just Luke Beasley on the
ground in Pickens South Carolina for the
Trump rally we also have these
incredible interviews done by right-wing
media including right side broadcasting
this one is maybe the sickest we've seen
a woman at the Trump rally in South
Carolina
said that Biden and others should be
taken to the train station
I I there's no way around this folks
she's talking about trains to
concentration camps
that's what this woman is talking about
and says it with no shame what should
president Trump do on day one when he
gets back in
lock him up right
a deep State take it down
the train station
take him to train station
I didn't say that that's even almost too
much for Marjorie Taylor Green's
boyfriend Brian Glenn Who does these
interviews this is what Nazis say
here's a guy at the Trump rally who told
Brian Glenn
Trump's trying to expose the Deep state
and Lindsey Graham's part of that deep
state I'm sure first you got to expose
the Deep State and he's been working on
that and working on it one of the
creatures is here Lindsey Graham
[Applause]
Brian Glenn also unsure whether he wants
to get involved in that of course one of
the things cultists often say when they
are constantly lied to by the cult
leader is that the cult leader is really
honest
here's what this woman had to say like
people are becoming more involved
right yeah yeah absolutely truth is a
revolution right now and that's not
something that we've had in a long time
it feels good it's refreshing to think
it's refreshing that Trump is so so so
honest so so so honest and then even
interviewing an 11 year old girl who has
been sadly brainwashed with the same
stuff says Trump's the only honest guy
left why are you excited to be here what
what made you
what is it that you like about Donald
Trump
he only tells the truth
big thing right tell them the truth
scary cult stuff
um we've got a great bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpakman.com remember
Alex Jones hates the bonus show well the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad Howard Stern likes the
bonus show but he won't pay for it a
David Pac-Man membership costs six bucks
a month yeah joinpakman.com my friends
that's the place to sign up we will see
you on the bonus show
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors for all of the
books I don't have time for I use short
form which condenses thousands of
non-fiction books down into an excellent
summary that I can read or listen to all
at once short form goes chapter by
chapter providing deeper analysis than
other summary platforms for a more
comprehensive understanding of any topic
try it free and get 25 off using my link
below